[Music]
watch out Prince Harry
it seems Megan Markel has a tiny new
admirer the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are on day two of their royal tour of
Ireland which has already included a
meet-and-greet with President Michael
Higgins his wife Sabina Coyne and their
two ginormous pooches ringing the peace
Bell and a wardrobe change for Megan the
Duchess flipped out of her gray Roland
Mireille dress and into a more casual
black Javan she pantsuit and a white
shirt underneath before the newlyweds
were off to their second event grieving
and cheering on athletes who were
participating in traditional Gaelic
sports at Dublin's Croke Park it's at
this second event that the Royals came
face to face with Walter Cullen an
adorable three-year-old who just
couldn't get enough of Megan's face and
hair while we've known for some time
Harry is a natural with the kiddos Megan
is quickly proving herself to check out
her huge smile and playful ways
throughout the sweet interaction we're
going to see how they are as a married
couple as a team how they're received
and yeah sets the tone for the future
next it was off to Dublin's Trinity
College a special appearance for Megan
in particular the 36 year old former
actress visited the school back in 2013
to accept the Bram Stoker medal for
entertainment for her role on soup it
meant everything to me
[Music]